the mandalorian season 3 trailer has
been leaked and i'm going to do a quick
breakdown of it unfortunately i cannot
show footage but i will be showing
screenshots just because i want to avoid
a copyright track one thing to note is
that we're going to see a lot more
mandalorians in this season we see this
smaller mandalorian looking helmet here
which some have been saying it could be
for grogu and it looks like the armorer
is holding this helmet also looks like
the scale for this season is going to be
massive so much more than the first two
seasons there's a lot of space battles
which we can see in the background here
i feel like this might be the best
season yet but i don't want to drink
anything in this shot here we have
mandalorians using what looks to be a
drop ship so they're dropping into
action and then we have bobby frick from
the rise of skywalker so it looks like
they're going to be connecting to the
sequels even more than they have in the
previous seasons which i know a lot of
people aren't going to be too happy
about that but perhaps they can work
their magic and improve the sequels in
some way or at least add on to the
characters in the sequels such as bobby
fricker bo katan's hairstyle is actually
clone wars acro and i gotta say it looks
really good and suits her well so it's a
nice little detail to see and at the end
of the trailer it looks like we see
mandalore which is really exciting
there's also some other things in a
trailer which i haven't broken down just
because i don't want to break down the
whole trailer in an image format in case
i get copyrighted but i will be leaving
a link to the trailer in the description
so you guys can watch it full for
yourself but if you do want to see a
part 2 of this breakdown let me know in
the comment section below thanks for
watching guys